mathieu julien aubert monsieur le
premier ministre
hier cinq serviteur de la france sont
morts hier en effet une avalanche en
savoie a fait 13 victimes dans les rangs
de la légion étrangère cinq disparus et
8 soldats blessés aujourd'hui le 2ème
régiment étranger de génie basé dans ma
circonscription de vaucluse est en deuil
cet événement tragique qui a eu lieu au
cours d'une sortie d'entraînement en
montagne à valfréjus en savoie frappe de
plein fouet la petite commune rurale de
saint christol qui accueille la base ce
régiment mais aussi tout le plateau
d'albion et plus largement le
département de vaucluse
je ne pense pas déformer la pensée des
vauclusiens en disant que nous sommes
tous fiers d'accueillir sur notre
territoire
ces sommes prêts à mourir pour la france
alors que nombre d'entre eux ne sont
pourtant pas français monsieur le
premier ministre
depuis sa création en 1999 ce n'est
hélas pas la première fois que le 2e rei
pas eu le prix du sang au service de
l'intérêt supérieur de notre nation
avant ce ainsi avant ce drame quatre
légionnaires avaient perdu la vie en
afghanistan entre 2010 et 2012 et entre
2012 et 2015 trois soldats ont péri lors
d'entraînements dont l'un dans des
circonstances similaires
j'ai été personnellement perturbé par
les débats stériles ans et sous certains
plateaux concernant les conditions de
cet accident
car je pense d'abord à leurs familles à
leurs collègues les hommes du 2è reg que
je connais bien ce sont des soldats
aguerris spécialiste du combat en haute
montagne
totalement dévoué pleinement conscient
du danger de chacune de leurs missions
c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais que vous
fassiez taire toute polémique en nous
précisant les conditions de l'exercice
qui était en cours pouvez vous nous
confirmer que ce drame est bien la
conséquence d'un accident et non pas
d'une impréparation l'honneur de ce
régiment d'élite est en jeu je
souhaiterais également que vous
informiez la représentation nationale
sur les dispositions que le gouvernement
entend prendre à l'égard de ceux qui
pleurent aujourd'hui un père un mari ou
un ami dans le cas où certains de ces
légionnaires ne seraient pas français
pouvez vous nous indiquer sur le
gouvernement prévoit de les nationaliser
à titre plus bas de l'est national de
leur donner la nationalité à titre
posthume
vous pouvez vous nous la parole est à
monsieur jean-marc défini secrétaire
d'état chargé des anciens combattants et
de la mémoire
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
aubert effectivement vous l'avez dit les
légionnaires ont payé encore un lourd
tribut hier dans le cadre de leur
préparation
une avalanche a emporté onze d'entre eux
5 ont trouvé la mort et deux sont
toujours dans un état grave
hospitalisé le ministre de la défense
jean yves le drian est toujours sur les
lieux
en ce moment nos pensées bien sûr vent
comme vous l'avez dit à leurs familles
mais aussi aux blessés qui sont
hospitalisés l' enquête
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
d'albertville pour déterminer les
conditions de ceux de ce drame
à ce stade nous savons que cette zone
d'exercice est connue et qu'elle est
utilisée par le groupe d'aguerrissement
en montagne
le drame de modane dans la région de
valfréjus l'ensemble de nos soldats
bénéficier de l'équipement adéquat pour
ce type d'activité est porté notamment
des balises avalanche le 2e régiment
étranger du génie de la légion étrangère
est une unité d'appui de la 27e brigade
d'infanterie de montagne ces
légionnaires suivent une formation
montagne adéquat qui correspond à cette
brigade
il dispose bien sûr des brevets
d'alpinistes et de skieurs militaire
enfin je peux vous garantir que les
qualifications d'encadrement nécessaires
étaient réunis le groupe disposait de
trois chef de détachement et de
plusieurs aides moniteurs en 7h triste
bien entendu je voudrais encore souligné
effet félicité les services de secours
des équipes de secours pour leur
réactivité nos pensées vont aux familles
entendu des militaires disparus et aux
blessés comme le président de la
république l'a dit hier nous les
assurons de la solidarité de la nation
je ne peux pas vous répondre sur les
questions précises vous avez donné mais
rassurez-vous tout effet lorsque un
soldat disparaît pour la prise en charge
de la famille
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur guillaume bachelay merci
monsieur